voici revenu le temps des masques masse
cloud papillon diaprées qui cache les
visages c'est bien connu
la mode est un éternel recommencement
près de soixante dix ans plus tard c'est
le retour du masque plumes de coq blanc
de marabouts des indes aigrettes noir
diamant et j'ai se mêlent dans cet
ensemble qui porte le nom de défi
peut-être pas de masque à plumes cette
année sur les podiums mais des
mannequins au visage découvert c'est has
been vraiment plus tendance
les créateurs de la fashion week sous
qu'ovide doivent respecter les gestes
barrières et heureusement invente eu
d'autres ont déjà réfléchi à des
solutions
vous savez quand on crée une collection
on essaie d'abord de ressentir la
demande de la demande des clients de
savoir ce que ce qu'elle aimerait porter
et la demande en 1970 c'est la visière
mesdames avec cette visière amovible en
plexiglas vous ne passerait plus
inaperçu
comble du chic l'associer à une
combinaison en latex noir et si les
plumes et les visières ne sont pas à
votre goût
pensez au deuxième visage imparable
contre le coc vide
parmi les aspects parisien de la saison
il faut faire une place de choix au
visage nouveau de nos bellamy masque de
plâtre nask de chair
en attendant c'est un jeu charmant que
se joue ces ravissantes aux têtes de
rechange quant à la manière de défiler
guy laroche a déjà trouvé la solution en
1971 j'ai voulu faire une présentation
qu'ils soient moins habituel il parlera
entre les mannequins deux mètres de
distance entre elles les mains en l'air
aucun contact physique
bravo guy les gestes barrières sont
respectés et pour cet été on a la
solution en maillot de bain mais sous
cellophane comme dans les années 60
recouvrir sans dissimuler protégés sans
occulter toutes les règles d'or du
conditionnement ont été transposées avec
audace et fantaisie
même la mariée il ya succombé en 2003
l'épidémie de strass a déjà nourrit la
créativité des couturiers et des
créateurs venus de hong kong ont voulu
profiter si je puis dire de l'épidémie
de pneumopathies on peut discuter de
l'intérêt de leur idée de fabriquer de
présenter des masques de protection
contre l'épidémie de pneumopathies des
masques bijoux ou plus austère des
masques à gaz
faites votre choix mesdames
[Musique]